das globale energie probleme auf einen
schlag lösen mit der kernfusion wäre das
möglich ein us unternehmen hat jetzt
angekündigt bereits bis zum ende des
jahrzehnts einen kommerziell
einsetzbaren fusionsreaktor zu bauen
nach angaben der firma ist es erst
kürzlich gelungen stabiles plasma bei 50
grad celsius erzeugen
das wäre der absolute kanten sprung
klicks um science and future los geht's
herzlich willkommen
saubere energie in schier unendliche
menge das ist die vision die mithilfe
der kernfusion zur realität werden soll
das wohl wichtigste forschungsprojekt in
diesem zusammenhang plant den deuterium
und tritium betrieb allerdings erst ab
dem jahr 2035 die montage des
internationalen forschungsreaktors etr
hat im sommer des vergangenen jahres
begonnen doch eine pressemitteilung aus
den usa sorgt jetzt für aufregung
demnach könnte die energiegewinnung per
kernfusion schon deutlich früher
beginnen das us-unternehmen tae
technologies behauptet tatsächlich das
ist erst vor kurzem gelungen sei stabil
des plasmas bei 50 millionen grad
celsius zu erzeugen dieser erfolg könnte
die basis dafür sein dass kommerzielle
fusionskraftwerke bereits in wenigen
jahren für saubere energie sorgen die
menschheit würde sich damit eine
unerschöpfliche energiequelle
erschließen und zwar ohne wind sonne öl
oder gas ja alle energieprobleme auf
dieser erde könnten somit möglicherweise
auf einen schlag gelöst werden denn bei
der kernfusion sind kernschmelzen und
möglich und zudem entstehen nur sehr
geringe mengen radioaktiver abfall der
schon nach wenigen jahrzehnten einfach
entsorgt werden kann und der meiste teil
kann dann wieder in neun reaktoren
recycelt werden also ist das wirklich
realistisch alle hintergrundinfos zu
diesem spannenden thema gibt es in
diesem video bereits seit vielen
jahrzehnten tüfteln forschungsteams
weltweit mit großer anstrengungen daran
die sonne zu imitieren konkret geht es
bei der kernfusion darum durch die
verschmelzung von wasserstoff atom
energie zu gewinnen so wie es eben auch
in der sonne passiert auf diesem wege
ließe sich tatsächlich eine sehr billige
energie
stellen und das fast in unbegrenzter
menge das muss man sich mal vorstellen
ein gramm der brennstoffe könnten in
einem fusionsreaktor so viel energie
liefern wie sie bei der verbrennung von
elf tonnen kohle entstehen das ganze
könnte zudem auch noch viel
umweltfreundlicher ablaufen denn bei der
kernfusionstechnik wird weder die natur
verschmutzt noch werden treibhausgase in
die atmosphäre abgegeben
neben der klimafreundlichkeit bringt
diese technologie einen weiteren vorteil
mit sich der ganze prozess ist sehr viel
ungefährlicher als die atom spaltung in
kernkraftwerken wie wir sie heute kennen
denn selbst bei einem unfall setzt ein
fusionsreaktor nicht die unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung frei wie ein
kernkraftwerk und zudem haben die
radioaktiven stoffe die hierbei
entstehen einer halbwertszeit von
jahrzehnten und eben nicht von
jahrmillionen so wie es eben beim
atomkraftwerk der fall ist nach 50
jahren können 30 bis 40 prozent des
materials ohne besondere vorkehrungen
entsorgt werden und der rest kann nach
ungefähr insgesamt 100 jahren wieder in
einem fusionsreaktor verwendet werden
ein großer weiterer unterschied zur
atomkraft die atomkerne werden in einem
fusionsreaktor fusioniert und nicht
gespalten also vereinfacht gesagt
zusammengebracht und bei dieser
verschmelzung wird dann eben eine menge
energie frei zwei leicht atome bilden
also ein schweres doch da die
gesamtmasse des neuen atoms geringer ist
als die der beiden einzeln fehlte etwas
die entstandene energie doch technisch
gesehen ist das eine riesige
herausforderung denn dazu müssen schwere
wasserstoff atomen namens tritium und
deuterium zueinander gebracht werden das
problem deren kerne stoßen sich ab der
trick dabei eine sehr heiße umgebung
inter projekt soll ein plasma mit einer
temperatur von achtung 150 millionen
grad erzeugt werden und das ist deutlich
heißer als in der sonne selbst bedingt
durch den geringen druck auf der erde
doch noch gibt es zwei große haken an
der kernfusionsforschung erstens die
technologie ist noch lange nicht
ausgereift und wird es jemals möglich
sein mehr energie zu produzieren als
reingesteckt wird dabei handelt es sich
um eine ganze menge denn das plasma wird
ja wirklich ultra hoch erhitzt wird es
den forschungsteams bereits in der nahen
zukunft klingen einen plasma strom in
einem fusionsreaktor dauerhaft am
brennen zu halten und welches material
hält den krassen belastungen an der
innenwand des plasma gefäßes über einen
längeren zeitraum stand zweitens die
kostenfrage denn die kernfusion ist
alles andere als günstig nach angaben
der bundesregierung hat die europäische
union im zeitraum zwischen 2014 und 2020
insgesamt 2,7 milliarden euro für das
projekt ausgegeben
in den gesamten bereich der
atomforschung gingen insgesamt sogar 5
milliarden euro dagegen haben alle nicht
nuklearen bereich nur knapp sechs
milliarden euro als zuschuss bekommen
darunter zählen natürlich auch die
erneuerbaren energien und genau das ist
ein großer kritikpunkt denn die riesige
menge an finanziellen mitteln die
bislang bereits in die fusionsforschung
geflossen ist fehlt nach angaben der
kritikerinnen und kritiker an anderer
stelle beispielsweise in der forschung
zur energieeffizienz und -speicherung
doch es sind nicht nur staatliche
projekte die sich mit der kernfusion
beschäftigen erst vor einiger zeit
hatten wir hier bei pixum future über
zwei private unternehmen berichtet die
das rennen um die kernfusion aufwischen
uckermark energy und carports busen
system setzen auf neuartige
hochtemperatur supraleiter und sind
optimistisch dass sie somit sogar die
riesigen großprojekte wie beispielsweise
e tag hinter sich lassen können jetzt
vermeldet ein weiteres unternehmen einen
erfolg in diesem bereich der reaktor des
us-unternehmens technologies heißt
normen und hier hat man es nach
firmenangaben geschafft ein stabiles
plasma bei über 50 millionen grad
celsius zu erzeugen und die vision von
der ehe sind riesig diese technik soll
jetzt weiterentwickelt werden so dass
sie bereits in wenigen jahren zum
kommerziellen einsatz kommen kann doch
was steckt eigentlich dahinter
das us unternehmen ist im jahr das sind
98 gegründet worden und sieben jahre
später 2015 konnte erstmals ein plasma
erzeugt werden vor vier jahren 2017 dann
ein weiterer erfolg damals war es
gelungen ein plasma in fusionsreaktor
normen für zehn millisekunden stabil zu
halten und schon dieser ist komplett
anders als alle anderen
forschungsreaktoren er ist nämlich nicht
kreisförmig angelegt sondern ein langer
zylinder klar ist auch dass das nicht
ausreicht um fusions strom zu erzeugen
dennoch war es so möglich dass das mal
genauer zu analysieren und zu optimieren
so kam das unternehmen dann auch dazu
noch mal einen anderen ansatz zu wählen
der sich von den anderen fuß
sekten abhebt das heißt plasma wird hier
nämlich von einem selbst erzeugte
magnetfeld stabil gehalten und das ist
der absolute hammer
ein externes magnetfeld wie es
beispielsweise beim großprojekt etat zum
einsatz kommt ist somit gar nicht
notwendig sprich riesige energiemengen
zum aufrechterhalten des magnetfeldes
sind so schon mal überflüssig und noch
besser mit steigender temperatur wird
das magnetfeld stabiler
es wird also mit steigenden temperaturen
nicht unbedingt schwieriger sondern
einfacher an die kernfusion zu kommen wo
die genauen unterschiede zu den
bisherigen fusions experimenten die
deutsche forschungsanlage wendelstein
7-x verfügt genau wie der europäische
forschungsreaktor iter über runde
reaktor kann man als brennstoffe werden
hier zudem soll terium und tritium
eingesetzt das unternehmen chf dagegen
selbst als brennstoffe wasserstoff am
bohrain das isotop bohr elf soll also
mit jeweils einem proton fusionieren der
fusionsreaktor norman hat eine
zylindrische form einen durchmesser von
knapp sieben metern ins ganze 24 meter
lang
darin wird eine temperatur von 50
millionen grad celsius erreicht so dass
ein start mit plasma entstehen kann
und das funktioniert nach
unternehmensangaben gut bis zu 600
experimente werden dazu pro monat
durchgeführt der aktuelle meilenstein
und bezieht sich nach angaben von der
auf die kontrolle und stabilisierung des
empfindlichen plasmas zudem konnte nach
unternehmensangaben eine positive
beziehung zwischen der reaktor
temperatur und den plasma einschluss
gemessen werden die kompakte lineare
konfiguration verbessert demnach also
dem platz war ein schluss bei steigenden
temperaturen
es wird also mit steigenden temperaturen
stabiler das unternehmen sieht sich also
durch den aktuellen erfolg darin
bestätigt dass sich das heiße plasma mit
einem gewissermaßen selbst erzeugte
magnetfeld stabilisiert und das ist
wahrhaftig ein meilenstein fest steht
dass du es unternimmt der hat nicht
wenige fans und investoren die letzten
fortschritte führten dazu dass das
unternehmen eine finanzierungsrunde
abschließen konnte insgesamt schossen
die investoren 880 millionen us-dollar
hinzu ti will damit unter anderem einen
weiteren reaktor bauen
geplant ist der bau einer
demonstrationsanlage namens kopernikus
hier sollen dann plasma temperaturen von
über 100 millionen grad c
es möglich werden dazu heißt es von th
dass diese technik bis ende des
jahrzehnts zitat auf die bedingung
skaliert werden die für ein
wirtschaftlich tragfähiges kommerzielles
fusionskraftwerk erforderlich sind das
wäre auch deutlich früher als es
möglicherweise beim internationalen
kampfes reaktor etat der fall sein
könnte hier soll das erste plasma im
jahr 2025 eingesetzt werden so dass die
forschungsteams mit ihren experimenten
beginnen können zehn jahre später erst
also 2035 könnte dann der neu delhi um
tritium betrieb beginnen durchbruch
rekord kernfusion in china erreicht auch
hier gibt es ja riesige fortschritte
also unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren diesen kanal hier direkt
unter dem video ist am button einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran